as a former teacher I saw plenty of kids
who were really talented really smart
had the ability to go to college
University but the reality is weren't
going to go there because the schools
that they went to were to put it mildly
absolutely Dreadful in which no learning
took place because bad behavior under
funding etc etc is there not something
to be said for having quotas for these
types of kids who have got a huge amount
of ability but because the education
system has to put it bluntly failed them
the universities can step in and maybe
help to actually propel them forward in
their careers
yeah I think there are two um methods
for attracting you know kids that are
having those kind of difficulties into
the university environment that also are
consonant with the principle of
colorblind equality treating people
equally and not giving you know favor or
punishment based on Ancestry you can do
a couple things one is uh there's a
great system in Texas that says
if you're in the top 10 of your high
school graduating class and any High
School in Texas you're automatically
admitted into the University of Texas
system and so what that does is there
are you know of course many affluent
Public Schools uh where much more than
the top 10 percent are going to college
they're qualified they're they're
habituated to it they're encouraged by
their parents but for those struggling
high schools everyone knows if you get
that top 10 percent you're in you can
get to College that's a way that I think
in a sense disproportionately benefits
those who are at the lower end of the
socioeconomic class by virtue of proxy
and including many minority students but
it does it in a neutral colorblind
manner that I think targets the the
right thing is saying if you're a top
performer at your at any one of our
Public Schools
um you you deserve a spot you deserve a
chance
um the other method that you can do and
I think that it that it's a method that
that is that is commonplace and
certainly happens in the State of
Florida is that you can reward
scholarships or or tuition reductions
based on socioeconomic status so if
you're coming from a family uh you know
like my family I had two lawyers as
parents uh you know I had to go for
those Merit Scholarships I was not
qualifying for those uh Financial need
scholarships that's fine uh but if
you're coming from someone who's say a
great student but comes from a
background where you have maybe one
parent or two parents you know working
minimum wage let's say
um I think that it's right and just and
good to give those folks a break if not
a a full break on tuition for public
universities for which they're qualified
but the third thing that's really
important is that
this is really what the SATs were
designed to do standardized tests in the
mid-century period the ivy league
universities were kind of an old boys
club uh where your dad went to Harvard
you went to Harvard your son went to
Harvard and so what they did is they
created these sat tests so that kids
from all over the United States and
inner cities and small towns and rural
areas could compete in a very uh
objective in a kind of quantitative
sense against all of their other peers
and what this allowed was for those
great Ivy League schools at the time and
those public universities as well to
find those uh those kids who were
immense talents who had the brains who
had the intelligence who had the the you
know the capacity to do well
um but weren't connected uh socially or
or administratively with the
universities this gave them an
opportunity to prove themselves and so
these are three solutions that I think
solved the problem where left and right
mostly agree but they do it in a manner
that doesn't create result commitment
hostility frustration and isn't also a
violation of our constitution
look I completely agree I don't
understand how anyone left or right can
essentially put forward the idea that
you are going to deny somebody a place
at a university or on a grad program for
the simple reason that they are the
wrong color skin or that they are the
wrong sex to me it's abhorrent
yeah I I I feel the same way and
sometimes I wonder it's a very very
simple uh conclusion it's a very simple
position it happens to be very popular
with large majorities of the public but
we're up against a bureaucracy in a
system that is
you totally and fully committed to just
the opposite I mean they want to create
a racial spoil system in which
individuals are punished or rewarded
based on their ancestry I find it uh
disgusting I find it abhorrent
um and and that's what I'm fighting
against it
foreign